neu ist allerdings gleich das erste
ressort innen und heimat dass eine frau
dieses ressort leitet nancy faeser die
51 jährige juristin aus hessen ist die
erste
bundesinnenministerium in deutschland
und sie wird jetzt sozusagen zur politik
zu ihrer vorstellung hier stellung
es ist mir eine große ehre dass ich
heute zum ersten mal im deutschen
bundestag reden darf
wir wollen mehr fortschritt wagen
fortschritt bedeutet sicherheit nur so
werden wir den notwendigen rückhalt für
veränderungen haben wir sind ein starkes
land die überwältigende mehrheit in
unserem land steht hinter unserer
demokratie und ihren institutionen die
überwältigende mehrheit verhält sich in
der pandemie solidarisch und
rücksichtsvoll und dieser
überwältigenden mehrheit möchte ich
heute im namen der bundesregierung
ausdrücklich meinen dank aussprechen
aber
zur wahrheit gehört auch die pandemie
zeigte risse in unserer gesellschaft
protest erschöpfung wut aber unsere
gesellschaft ist nicht gespalten und wir
lassen uns auch nicht spalten wir sind
ein land und halten zusammen
der wissenschaftlerinnen journalisten
polizistinnen oder politiker attackiert
oder einschüchtert der führt keine
diskussionen mehr wir sehen hier keine
spaziergänge sondern organisierte
aktionen an vielen orten gleichzeitig
immer wieder mit gewalt immer wieder mit
massenhaften verstößen gegen korona
regeln
rechtsextremisten gewinnen leider
zunehmend regional an einfluss die
kämpfen nicht gegen krohne die kämpfen
gegen unsere demokratie meine damen und
herren ich
möchte sehr klar sagen wir lassen uns
das nicht bieten unsere demokratie ist
wehrhaft bei gewalt muss der rechtsstaat
hart durchgreifen die täterinnen und
täter müssen mit konsequenter
strafverfolgung rechnen
den polizistinnen und polizisten die
gerade jetzt für uns alle den kopf
hinhalten danke ich sehr herzlich
sie haben unsere große unterstützung ich
weiß wie schwer ihr job in diesen tagen
ist ich habe mir am montagabend während
der proteste im lagezentrum der polizei
in dresden selbst davon ein bild gemacht
allen die protestieren weil die impfung
sie umtreibt sage ich natürlich gehört
protest zur demokratie natürlich hören
wir zu aber wir lassen sie aber lassen
sie sich nicht von extremisten vor den
karren spannen grenzen sie sich ab von
hass und gewalt meine damen und herren
wir
stellen uns
menschenverachtung und gefährlichen
verschwörungs ideologien klar entgegen
das gilt bei corona demonstrationen und
das gilt überall sonst auch und gerade
im netz bei telegramm genauso wie auf
anderen plattformen es darf keinen
zweifel daran geben wir werden dafür
sorgen dass hetzer identifiziert und zur
verantwortung gezogen werden
meine damen und herren sicherheit ist
auch eine frage der sozialen
gerechtigkeit
wir wollen ein land sein in dem alle
menschen frei und ohne angst leben ganz
gleich in welchem viertel sie leben wen
sie lieben woran sie glauben oder woher
ihre familien einmal kam wir haben alle
extremistischen bedrohungen im blick den
islamismus den rechtsextremismus und den
linksextremismus
aber die größte gefahr für unsere
demokratie ist der rechtsextremismus und
und deshalb hat die bekämpfung des
rechtsextremismus es für mich auch die
besondere priorität meine damen und
herren
eines möchte ich leicht zu beginn sagen
es ist unser aller pflicht für den
schutz von jüdinnen und juden zu sorgen
die hetze die viele dieser tage in
unserem land noch erleben müssen ist
eine schande für unser land
meine damen und herren der mord am
kasseler regierungspräsidenten dr walter
lübke der antisemitische anschlag in
halle die rassistischen morde in hanau
diese entsetzlichen verbrechen lassen
mich nicht los die jahrelange
auseinandersetzung mit dem terror des
nsu haben mich persönlich sehr geprägt
deshalb sage ich auch heute hier im
deutschen bundestag der staat ist den
opfern weitere antworten schuldig die
aufarbeitung muss weitergehen und wir
werden sie vorantreiben
serpil themis unwahrheit den kran ihren
sohn fahrrad verloren was sie gesagt hat
ist eine mahnung an uns alle ich zitiere
unsere kinder dürfen nicht umsonst
gestorben sein ihr tod muss das ende
rassistischer angriffe seien
ich kann jeden lieben frau unwahr und
allen familien der opfer von hanau sagen
wir werden ihre kinder nie vergessen und
wir werden alles dafür tun um die
menschen die in unserem land bedroht
werden und angegriffen werden besser zu
schützen und deshalb meine damen und
herren werde ich auch als
bundesinnenministerium bis ostern einen
aktionsplan gegen rechtsextremismus
vorlegen
wir werden alles daransetzen
radikalisierung zu stoppen rechtsextreme
netzwerke zu zerschlagen und extremisten
konsequent die waffen zu entziehen das
ist die eine seite der medaille die
zweite seite ist engagement ist
politische bildung und ganz viel
prävention für beides werde ich mich
gleichermaßen einsetzen wir werden
demokratische initiativen verlässlich
unterstützen gemeinsam mit
familienministerin eines spiegel möchte
ich mit dem demokratie fördergesetz
dafür so schnell wie möglich eine neue
grundlage schaffen
meine damen und herren wir werden unsere
polizei und sicherheitsbehörden stärken
wir werden für respekt für ihre harte
arbeit und gute ausbildung und faire
arbeitsbedingungen sorgen zum beispiel
mit einer schnellen einführung der
ruhegehalts fähigkeit der polizei zulage
wir werden besser als früher aus fehlern
lernen und wir werden die balance von
freiheit und sicherheit waren
sicherheit bedeutet schutz vor
extremismus und sicherheit bedeutet
schutz vor kriminalität drei prioritäten
möchte ich darüber hinaus nennen wir
werden die bekämpfung von organisierter
kriminalität von kleinkriminalität und
cyberkriminalität verstärken wir werden
alles unternehmen um kinder vor
sexualisierter gewalt zu schützen und
die täter und ihre netzwerke zu
verfolgen meine damen und herren und wir
werden die gewalt gegen frauen bekämpfen
und die strukturellen ursachen dafür
auch angehen meine damen und herren
ich bin auch ministerin für heimat
heimat sind alle menschen egal wo sie
herkommen heimat ist wo ich mich nicht
groß erklären muss heimat ist das zb in
sportvereinen jeden tag an integration
gelebt wird ich werde all denen den
rücken stärken die sich für uns alle
einsetzen das sind kommunalpolitisch
aktive das sind freiwillige und
ehrenamtliche
das sind engagierte in kirchen und
religionsgemeinschaften das sind
feuerwehrleute und thw helferinnen wie
alle diese menschen unsere gesellschaft
zusammenhalten haben wir auch nach der
furchtbaren flutkatastrophe im letzten
sommer gesehen die folgen des
klimawandels treffen uns hier und heute
daraus müssen wir jetzt konsequenzen
auch für einen starken
bevölkerungsschutz ziehen auch das wird
eine der wichtigen aufgaben der neuen
regierung sein
sehr geehrte abgeordnete wir sind stolz
darauf dass wir ein vielfältiges
einwanderungsland sind und wir sagen
dass auch endlich deutlich
jetzt wollen wir ein besseres
integrationsland werden uns geht es um
bildungschancen und arbeit von anfang an
wir schaffen ein modernes ein
wandlungsrecht auch und gerade um
arbeitskräfte zu gewinnen die wir
benötigt brauchen wir stehen zu unserer
humanitären verantwortung für
geflüchtete menschen
wir ermöglichen legale fluchtwege damit
das sterben im mittelmeer endlich ein
ende hat
wir sorgen für zügige asylverfahren und
gute perspektive für menschen die gut
integriert sind wir sorgen aber auch das
sage ich auch deutlich für konsequente
rückführung insbesondere von straftätern
die ampel koalition steht für einen
neuen geist und ein neues handeln in der
migrationspolitik legen wir damit los
neue kräfte setzen wir auch in der
digital politikfrei wir wollen eine
digitale verwaltung die aus der
perspektive der bürgerinnen und bürger
gedacht ist mit einem digital checks
werden wir gesetze darauf abklopfen ob
sie das leben einfacher und digitaler
machen und als bundesinnenministerium
wollen wir vorreiter und antreiber für
den digitalen start sein wir haben uns
viel vorgenommen
fortschritt braucht sicherheit dafür
setzt sich jetzt eine sehr gute
zusammenarbeit zwischen allen
demokratinnen und demokraten so werden
wir das vertrauen in unsere demokratie
stärken und für eine offene gesellschaft
werben und sie gegen unsere feinde
verteidigen herzlichen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
können sie noch einen moment hier
verweilen weil der kollege dr andré hahn
hat das wort zu einer kurzintervention
andere haben von berlin
ja sehr geehrte frau ministerin zu ihren
ausführungen zum thema wird dann meine
fraktionskollegin martina renner
sprechen ich möchte zudem etwas sagen
zudem sie gar nichts gesagt haben einmal
ist das das wort sportverein gefallen
sie sind auch sportministerin wir haben
in wenigen tagen olympische und
paralympische spiele die vereine haben
erhebliche schwierigkeiten mit den
corona maßnahmen und den einschränkungen
die damit verbunden sind ganze liegen in
verschiedenen sportarten brechen ihre
saison sub können die meisterschaften
nicht mehr fortsetzen es sind
einnahmeausfälle durch keiner
vorhandenen zuschauer oder durch weniger
zuschauer die zugelassen sind usw ich
hätte schon erwartet dass sie in ihrer
rede als sportministerin auf dieses
thema wenigstens mit einigen bemerkungen
eingehen und deshalb ist es für mich
wichtig von ihnen zu erfahren wie wollen
sie den vereinen den sportverbänden ganz
konkret helfen in dieser schwierigen
situation das wird auch erwartet dass
sie dazu stellung beziehen
wenn sie mögen können sie das jetzt tun
das mache ich sehr gerne damit gewinne
ich die notwendige zeit um natürlich zu
dem wichtigen bereich sport auch etwas
zu sagen hätte ich mehr zeit gehabt
hätte ich diesen wichtigen themen
und ich würde ihnen gerne zu rufen dass
ich das natürlich im blick habe
insbesondere die sport liegen die darauf
angewiesen sind dass die zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer haben das ist im
basketball im handball volleyball der
fall die brauchen jetzt unsere
unterstützung und die werden sie auch
von der bundesregierung erhalten meine
damen und herren wir stehen hinter dem
ortsausgang
aber es ist nicht nur der profisport
sind auch die vielen ehrenamtlichen die
im sport unterwegs sind die dieser tage
unsere unterstützung benötigen und
deswegen werden wir auch dort sehr stark
unterstützen und wenn sie mir schon die
gelegenheit geben zum sport etwas zu
sagen dann werde ich auch von dieser
stelle noch einmal wiederholen dass ich
persönlich nicht an den olympischen
spielen in peking teilnehmen werde
nancy faeser die neue deutsche
innenminister ist natürlich auch für den
sport zuständig für heimat allerdings
anders als ihr vorgänger für bauen und
wohnen nicht mehr da hat die ampel
regierung ja ein neues ministerium
geschaffen nancy faeser ist eine von
einigen ministern in der ampel regierung
die nicht mitglied im hohen hause ist
also nicht mdb gewählt ist aber das geht
ja ein bundesminister muss nicht
bundestagsabgeordneter oder
bundestags-abgeordnete sein andrea
lindholz jetzt csu sie war bis vor
kurzem die vorsitzende des
innenausschusses und ist jetzt für
diesen bereich stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
frau bundesministerin sie sind die erste
frau an der spitze des
bundesinnenministeriums und dazu
gratuliere ich ihnen über tab über die
parteigrenzen hinweg und ich wünsche
ihnen auch viel erfolg
zu übernehmen dieses wichtige amt in
unruhigen zeiten der rechtsextremismus
ist derzeit eine zentrale bedrohung für
die sicherheit in deutschland und das
hat auch ihr vorgänger horst seehofer
immer wieder betont sie setzen das jetzt
fort die morde an weiter lücke in halle
und auch in hanau haben gezeigt wie
gefährlich der rechtsterrorismus ist und
eines steht fest sie haben uns im kampf
gegen den rechtsextremismus
fest an ihrer seite aber für uns als
union ist es wichtig dass der kampf
gegen jede form von extremismus
entschlossen geführt wird wir haben in
der letzten wahlperiode viele tausend
neue stellen geschaffen bei der
bundespolizei beim bundeskriminalamt und
beim verfassungsschutz damit extremisten
und kriminelle auf breiter front
bekämpft werden personal allein aber
reicht nicht aus denn unsere behörden
brauchen auch moderne befugnisse um im
digitalen zeitalter
erfolgreich ermitteln zu können und im
koalitionsvertrag der ampel steht hierzu
rein gar nichts drin und auch in ihrer
rede haben sie hierzu heute nichts
gesagt der vertrag ist an dieser stelle
eher geprägt vom misstrauen gegenüber
unseren sicherheitsbehörden
und ich stelle mir die frage wie der
verfassungsschutz seine rolle als
frühwarnsystem unserer demokratie
erfüllen und extremistische netzwerke
aufklären soll wenn es ihm genau diese
instrumente verweigern die ampel will
nämlich sinnvolle befugnisse wie die
quellen ticker und die
online-durchsuchung für den
verfassungsschutz und die bundespolizei
entweder einschränken oder weiterhin
vollständig verhindern man muss sich mal
vorstellen
festnetztelefonen die dürfen in
besonderen fällen abgehört werden aber
wenn der extremisten whatsapp nutzen
soll dann soll der verfassungsschutz
außen vor bleiben das ist und bleibt
realitätsfern und einen entschlossenen
kampf gegen extremisten und
schwerkriminelle der sieht in unserer
digitalen welt beileibe anders raus
und rechtsextremismus ist auch nicht die
einzige bedrohung für unser land der
generalbundesanwalt führt aktuell weit
über 500 verfahren mit bezug auf
islamistischen terrorismus die es
rückkehrer bilder ein massives risiko
verschwörungstheoretiker die auf corona
demonstrationen versuchen mit absurden
erzählungen unseren staat zu
delegitimieren und auch
linksextremistische gewalt und angriffe
auf polizisten nehmen massiv zu unser
rechtsstaat muss nach allen seiten hin
wehrhaft und wachsam bleiben und hier
ptc frau bundesinnenministerium das
nicht nur in worten sondern auch in
taten anzukündigen beziehungsweise
umzusetzen sie haben ausgeführt sie
wollen den extremismus mit einem
demokratie fördergesetz bekämpfen und
die zivilgesellschaft noch mehr fördern
ja das ist nicht grundsätzlich falsch
aber sie sollten auch genau prüfen wen
sie da fördern wir haben als union immer
gesagt extremismus darf man nicht mit
extremisten bekämpfen und linke
gewalttäter der antifa sind auch sicher
keine hilfe gegen rechtsextremismus das
heißt
wir haben schon in der letzten
wahlperiode die wiedereinführung der
demokratie klausel gefordert das hat
ihre fraktion abgelehnt aber ein
bekenntnis zur demokratie und zum
rechtsstaat ist gerade bei der
politischen bildung von der sie heute
auch angedeutet haben dass sie ihn
wichtig ist extrem wichtig und auch bei
der extremismus prävention sicherlich
nicht viel nicht zu viel verlangt
soweit ich heute ihnen einmal täglich an
lesen konnte dass sie der auffassung
waren dass im bereich
extremismusbekämpfung zu wenig geschehen
sei will ich ihnen nur kurz zu rufen
dass das dass das kabinett bereits ende
2020 der vorgänger-regierung zum thema
rechtsextremismus und rassismus 89
maßnahmen beschlossen und umgesetzt hat
und allein eine milliarde euro für die
jahre 20 21 bis 22 als sonder milliarde
beschlossen hat ich empfehle ihnen auch
da erst genauer anzuschauen was schon
alles auf den weg gebracht worden ist
bevor sie dann auch neue maßnahmen in
frankreich
das waffenrecht wo man sie anfassen sie
haben das heute gesagt es ist korrekt
waffen gehören nicht in die hand von
extremisten nicht extremisten ich will
ihnen aber auch nur hier sagen wir haben
hier viel gemacht und wir müssen schon
aufpassen dass wir eine waffenrecht mit
augenmaß behalten und nicht die vielen
millionen redlichen jäger und schützen
in deutschland unter generalverdacht
stellen deshalb brauchen wir eines
augenmaß und kein aktionismus für die
linke galerie und auch da werden wir
genau aufpassen
und einen letzten punkt den ich noch
ansprechen will ist die steuerung und
begrenzung von migration eine der großen
aufgaben in der innenpolitik die union
hat die asyl integration deutlich
begrenzt und gleichzeitig ein modernes
fachkräfte einwanderungsgesetz umgesetzt
und ich will nur sagen das geht im
übrigen für talente mit und ohne
arbeitsvertrag nur weil wir vorhin von
herrn scholz gehört haben dass wir nicht
das wäre nicht so als ich empfehle ihnen
erst einmal die tatsächlichen barrieren
abzuschaffen bevor sie das gesetz ändern
und dafür zu sorgen dass wir mehr
fachkräfte aus europa holen da ist
teilweise immer noch die
jugendarbeitslosigkeit von 30 prozent da
bevor wir wieder anfangen die ganze welt
einzuladen denn deutschland ist nach wie
vor hauptziel land für irreguläre
migration bei uns steigen die zahlen
wieder an den eu-außengrenzen
gehen sie wieder zurück ich habe mit
freude zur kenntnis genommen dass sie
sagen es darf keinen deutschen
alleingang geben wenn ich dann aber frau
berg hören die uns sagt er italien
alleine gelassen und müssten jetzt
wieder vorangehen in deutschland da muss
ich schon sagen ich frag mich ehrlich wo
ihr kompass ist und zu behaupten horst
seehofer der die bundesregierung die
vormalige habe italien allein gelassen
tut mir leid das hat mit der realität
überhaupt nichts zu tun
abschließend will ich noch darauf
hinweisen dass über
100000 personen in deutschland mit asyl
bezug offiziell arbeitslos gemeldet sind
und es ist schon ein großes thema das
wir nicht asyl und arbeitsmigration
miteinander vermischen genau das haben
sie vor sie wollen den spurwechsel
einführen eine solche migrationspolitik
schade unsere gesellschaft spaltet
unsere gesellschaft und was sie damit
wieder einmal wagen ist kein fortschritt
sondern chaos und davor kann ich nur
warnen vielen dank
andrea lindholms hat noch einmal
stellung genommen nämlich zu dem neuen
geist in der migrationspolitik der weg
zum deutschen pass und der ampel
regierung kürzer werden und andre linken
und es hat ja ein paar zahlen genannt
und gewarnt davor die migration nach
deutschland in der form zu erleichtern
die zwischen im deutschen bundestag hat
nun die kollegin lamya kaddor für die
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen das wort
ja etwas gesagt lamya kaddor ihre erste
rede und gleich in ihrer ersten
legislaturperiode ist sie
innenpolitische sprecherin der
bündnisgrünen geworden
diesem hohen haus im deutschen bundestag
reden zu dürfen und mein weg war nicht
immer frei von stellen nun sicherlich
bin ich kampferprobt wenn es um den
einsatz gegen jede form von
menschenfeindlichkeit und eine stark und
für eine starke vielfältige gesellschaft
geht dafür werde ich mich immer
einsetzen ich stehe als deutsche und als
tochter syrischer einwanderer deren
eltern es nie für möglich gehalten
hätten ihr kind an dieser stelle
sprechen zu hören das was für viele von
ihnen geschätzte kolleginnen und
kollegen vielleicht selbstverständlich
ist nämlich aus besser aus der
perspektive einer mehrheit zu sprechen
und selbstverständlich ihren eigenen
platz in dieser gesellschaft einzunehmen
stellt sich für mich als etwas größere
herausforderung war ich wie viele andere
hier im saal mussten diesen platz in
dieser gesellschaft erst einmal finden
und ich muss ihnen bis heute übrigens
regelmäßig verteidigen gegen
menschenfeinde und demokratie hat doch
das ergebnis ist offensichtlich mein
platz ist nun hier
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen die
zahl der neu gemeldeten cupid 19 fälle
in europa hat sich nach angaben
innerhalb von zwei wochen mehr als
verdoppelt wie in einem brennglas zeit
muss das virus zeigt uns diese pandemie
die gesellschaftlichen herausforderung
und stellt uns poldi zu reißen wir grüne
sind als teil der regierungsfraktionen
angetreten diese gesellschaftlichen
herausforderungen endlich anzugehen und
die aufgaben die vor uns liegen sind
gewaltig es ist festzuhalten
unsere demokratie ist stark und lebendig
die demokratinnen in diesem land sind
weit mehr als sie nicht demokratie liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen es ist unser
aller verpflichtung unserer verfassung
zu hüten und uns deutlich gegen
menschenfeinde jeglicher couleur zu
positionieren
denn gleichzeitig wir unsere demokratie
bedroht sie steht aus unterschiedlichen
sie steht und aus unterschiedlichen
ideologischen richtungen unter beschuss
ganz besonders von rechten netzwerken
oder bewegungen wie den identitäten und
nicht zuletzt von querdenkern wenn aber
die organisatorische strukturen hinter
einer vielzahl von unangemeldeten
demonstration verbrämt als angebliche
spaziergänge von rechten netzwerken
betrieben werden vor allen dingen über
telegramm und wenn in diesen chats seit
mitte november mehr als 250
tötungsdelikte tötungs aufrufe gefunden
werden die sich gegen politiker innen
wissenschaftler/innen ärztinnen und
ärzten journalistinnen und journalisten
wenden dann gefährdet das die innere
sicherheit und die unversehrtheit von
menschen in diesem land dann müssen wir
durch diese unterwanderung sogenannter
spaziergänge durch rechtsextreme
netzwerke davon ausgehen dass es zu
schweren staatsgefährdenden taten kommen
kann und damit ich hier aber nicht
falsch verstanden werde menschen die
sich gegen die impfpflicht oder gegen
die korona maßnahmen aussprechen wollen
sollen das unbedingt tun dürfen die
verantwortung aber mit wem man und nicht
nur sinnbildlich untergehakt auf dem
muss mit läuft trägt jede einzelne jeder
einzelne selbst
der präsident in meine damen und herren
freiheit und sicherheit sind
fundamentale werte für die diese
koalition gleichermaßen einsteht sie hat
sicherheitsbehörden zu schützen
sicherheitsleute schützenden rechtsstaat
aber der staat muss auch seine
bediensteten schützen das gilt gerade
auch für die polizistinnen und
polizisten bei dem mehr als 1000
protestaktionen gegen staatlicher
maßnahmen zur bekämpfung der korona
pandemie am montag insgesamt verletzt
wurden ich möchte den verletzten in den
reihen der polizei von hier aus gute
besserung wünschen und mich für ihren
einsatz auch gedanken aber
dank allein reicht nicht aus daher haben
wir im koalitionsvertrag vereinbart dass
die polizei besser ausgestattet wird das
ist längst überfällig und wurde von der
vorgängerregierung vernachlässigt das
gehen wir jetzt an und liebe frau
bundesinnenminister und phaser da bin
ich zuversichtlich es wird uns gelingen
wenn sich sicherheitsbehörden an der
zunehmenden gewaltbereitschaft
ausgesetzt sehen ist es unsere aufgabe
diese zum wohle aller zu stärken aber
auch in den reihen der
sicherheitsbehörden gibt es
verfassungsfeindliche tendenzen die wir
mit aller härte angehen werden als
wissenschaftlerin zum islamistischen
terrorismus muss ich darüber hinaus
feststellen ohne nachrichtendienste wäre
eine bekämpfung und denkbar aber die
parlamentarische kontrolle der
nachrichtendienste muss besser werden
wir schaffen deshalb die überfällige
gesetzliche regelung für den einsatz von
v personen aller sicherheits gehören
daher braucht es auch eine
gesamtstrategie die auf prävention die
radikalisierung und effektiver
gefahrenabwehr basiert und zwar für den
rechten terror die in kassen und hanau
genauso wie für den islamistischen
terror am breitscheidplatz was wir aber
auch brauchen ist endlich eine
staatliche etikette im umgang mit opfern
von gewalt und nationalen katastrophen
diese menschen fühlen sich von uns
allein gelassen und das viel zu lange
schon daher führen wir den 11 märz für
den 11 märz einen nationalen gedenktag
für die opfer terroristischer gewalt ein
als innenpolitische sprecherin bin ich
auch für religionspolitik zuständig ich
bin froh in einem land zu leben das so
vielen religionen eine heimat ist es ist
unsere historische verantwortung dabei
sicherzustellen dass gerade jüdinnen und
juden sich in deutschland sicher fühlen
können gegen alle formen von
antisemitismus werden die jüdische
einrichtung stärker beschützen und juden
mit juden persönlich auch
antisemitischen hass und hetze im netz
treten wir entschieden entgegen
vergleiche von corona verharmlosen oder
gar leugnen mit dem vergleich und dem
leid der opfer hat mich das ns-regime
dürfen wir nicht länger hinnehmen
und viele werden es gar nicht wissen der
islam wird schon ganz lange zu
deutschland seit dem achtzehnten
jahrhundert es ist daher überfällig dass
ihr ausbildungsprogramm für imame und
deutsche universitäten ausbauen auch das
packen wir jetzt an und hierbei das
liegt mir sehr am herzen
wer wegen dialog mit progressiven
islamischen gemeinden intensivieren und
in diese prozesse einbinden
es ist nicht hinnehmbar wenn wir an
silvester in iserlohn gräber geschändet
werden egal ob diese muslimisch jüdisch
christlich oder buddhistisch sind wie
alcoa die als chor stehen für aufbruch
und wandel lassen sie uns diesen
aufbruch und wandel gemeinsam mit ihnen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
opposition gemeinsam für ein besseres
land und eine bessere stärkere
gesellschaft gestalten denn ein altes
chinesisches sprichwort lautet wenn der
wind der veränderung weht bauen die
einen mauern und die anderen finden
vielen dank
lamya kaddor mit viel applaus
vereinigung aus ihrer funktion aber ich
glaube wenn hier der ein oder andere
applaudiert ebenfalls für die grüne die
hier heute ihre erste minister skride
absolviert hat
kurios innenpolitischer sprecher und er
redet von der tribüne
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
der koalitionsvertrag das aberwitzige
völkermords programm des global compact
auf migration jetzt als deutsche gesetze
barrierefreier zugang für schatz suchen
da aus aller welt und mit turbo in die
wahlkabine die macher wollen ja auch was
davon haben das kostet bisher schon 50
milliarden jährlich und funktioniert
nicht aber herr lindner der lieber
falsch regiert als gar nicht der hat ja
die druckerpresse für das wertlose
brüsseler betrugs geld soll tag und
nacht weiter rattern die rasende
deutsche schuldenuhr dreht bereits durch
lebenslanges schuldhaft für unsere
kinder und enkel aber hauptsache man
schüttet fake milliarden aus über
bankrott der eu staaten also die ampel
will den paradigmenwechsel um illegale
migration zu verhindern müsse man legale
wege schaffen man würde wohl als antwort
auf ladendiebstahl die ware gleich mit
dem schild zum mitnehmen aufstellen
hunderttausende abgelehnte asylbewerber
die den staat mit behaupteter
schutzbedürftigkeit und betrogen haben
werden nicht nur seit 20.15 geduldet
jetzt sollen sie als sogenannte
integrierte bleiberecht kriegen
ausländer bis 27 ohnehin
staatsbürgerschaft schon nach drei
jahren schließlich stehen auch mal
wieder wahlen an dafür senkung der
sprachanforderungen und mehrfach
staatsbürgerschaften damit auch wirklich
alle links wählen können wer seine
identität verschleiern will geht einfach
gibt einfach eine versichern kann
versuchen sie das mal bei ihren impfpass
mehr mittelmeer schlepperei mehr
umsiedlung nach deutschland mehr
afghanen 25.000 weitere von afghanistan
nach absurdistan ist es anscheinend gar
nicht soweit
alle wirtschaftsmigranten und asyl
touristen weit sollen übersicht sichere
staaten nach deutschland kommen und hier
versorgt werden da wird klar wer die
400.000 neuen wohnungen jährlich
beziehen soll da trifft sich der grüne
einwanderungs lobbyist mit dem gelben
wirtschafts lohndrücker lobbyisten der
deutsche mieter und arbeitnehmer saß
offenbar nicht am koalitionstisch ein
schleichender abbau der demokratie soll
es möglich machen man tut nichts gegen
ja befeuert die verbreitung von hass und
hetze gegen andersdenkende durch
regierungs fernsehen und kartell
parteien aber die innenministerin will
gegen telegramm vorgehen wir sagen wer
meinungsfreiheit und plurale diskussion
will der beauftragt nicht netzzensur
wer wie die fünf und demokratischen
fraktionen der altparteien seine
mehrheit dazu missbraucht eine
minderheits kraft die eigens vorgesehene
repräsentanz in präsidium und
ausschüssen zu nehmen der hat der idee
der repräsentativen vertretung des
deutschen volkes im bundestag der
repräsentativen demokratie überhaupt den
krieg erklärt
wer wie die cdu sachsen das
demonstrations- grundrecht mit einer
beschränkung auf zehn personen faktisch
aufheben will der also im grunde noch
mit völlig fadenscheinigen gründen im
freien der zeigt dass er sich sein
politisches überleben nur noch durch
aufhebung der oppositions grundrechte
vorstellen kann das scheint bei der
innenministerin mit ihrer fakten
befreiten diffamierung von
regierungskritischen friedlichen
spaziergang ganz ähnlich zu sein wer
zweig stadt 3g auferlegt also negativ
getesteten gesunden grundlos ihre rechte
verwehrt hat gesundheits argumente als
vorgeschobene lügen selbst entlarvt
betreibt nur noch schikanierung von
ungeimpften zur errichtung eines panik
gepuffert totalitarismus wer die gehirne
der wähler durch cannabis freigabe
vernebeln will wer im gefüge bis dahin
der mann zu befördern an ein opiumkrieg
gegen die eigenen bürger arbeitet der
will dann auch kinderwahlrecht
organisieren für die freitäglichen
schulschwänzer worden die nicht mehr zu
selbst denkern ausgebildet sondern zu
propaganda schreien zugerichtet werden
sollen
merkel ist weg das system merkel regiert
eine gigantische enteignung des
deutschen staats volks auf allen ebenen
grundrechte skurrilität staatsgrenzen
finanzen kultur das ist sie dann wohl
die gepriesene kontinuität der regierung
das früher merkel gröhe die
deutschlandfahne entreißt und angewidert
in die ecke schmeißt heute harbeck
vaterlandsliebe zum kotzen findet nicht
überraschend ist er der mit deutschland
nichts anzufangen weiß mit seinem
morgenthau plan der kompletten
deindustrialisierung deutschlands die
fleischgewordene abrissbirne unseres
wohlstands wir fordern illegale
zurückweisen anreize abstellen endlich
abschieben sozialstaat für unsere bürger
statt asylmissbrauchs paradies humanität
heißt nicht ganze völker scharen über
den globus zu treiben und die wandernden
wie die aufnehmende zu ent heimaten wir
brauchen keine werbeaktion für
massenimmigration kein aufbauprogramm
für klaren bildung keinen ausverkauf
deutscher bürgerrechts in aller welt wir
wollen unser land unsere lebensweise und
unsere verfassungsordnung bewahren aber
mit zustrom zu staatsgebiet und
wahlkabine will die ampel ein eigenes
wahl volk rekrutieren auch mittels einer
kultur die die rechte von frauen und
anderen religionen nicht akzeptiert ihr
sagen wehret den anfängen
letztes jahr gab es stand herbst
gefährder die islamistische gut 550
gegenüber rechtsextremistischen gut 70 9
geleitete terrorverfahren islamistische
210 rechtsextreme 5 ja ist denn ein
politisches fake narrativ von
rechtsextremer größter bedrohung
wichtiger als der schutz der bevölkerung
verwirklichen gefährdern wird
kollidieren für einen ideologie
befreiten rundumblick es geht um die
sicherheit der bürger
meine damen und herren 3 von vier
wählern wollen die spd nicht 75 85
wollen diese grünen nicht komplize bei
der pervertierung des parlamentarischen
systems ist die fdp schon loriot wusste
liberal heißt im liberalen sinne nicht
nur liberal offenbar heißt es manchmal
auch einfach macht geil schluss mit
dieser koalition der verlierer
schluss mit mehr religiöse und mobbing
und kopftuch terror gegen mädchen an den
schulen bei weniger leistung schluss
mittelmeer deutschem geld für
ausländische ansprüche bei weniger
stimmrecht in der eu schluss mit weniger
demokratie in deutschland bei umwandlung
von einer freien nation für einem
willfährigen hebel totaler
globalisierung bei totale ausbeutung für
fremde interessen
meine damen und herren eine spd
politiker warnte ich darf zitieren wir
haben uns mit dem zustand von menschen
aus völlig anderen kulturellen welten
übernommen 7 millionen ausländer in
deutschland sind eine fehlerhafte
entwicklung und zitat wir müssen eine
zuwanderung aus fremden kulturen
unterbinden zuwanderung von menschen aus
anatolien und schwarzafrika schafft nur
ein zusätzliches deko populär
vernünftiger einstellungen dieser spd
heute steht für das gegenteil und helmut
schmidt helmut schmidt helmut schmidt er
er wäre heute in der afg meine damen und
herren
dass
das wort hat der kollege konstantin
kohler für die fdp fraktion sowie coole
ist jetzt stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender werden er war in
der letzten legislaturperiode der
innenpolitik
ich wünsche ihnen im namen der fraktion
der freien demokraten alles gute und
viel erfolg für diese wichtige aufgabe
als bundesinnenministerium das ist eine
anspruchsvolle aufgabe und sie sind ja
nicht nur verantwortlich für die innere
sicherheit sondern für eine ganze reihe
an themen die hier angesprochen worden
sind und dazu gehört auch das thema des
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalts und es
ist genau dieser gesellschaftliche
zusammenhalt der momentan in unserem
land besonders auf die probe gestellt
wird und das liegt an der korona
pandemie wir sind jetzt bei knapp zwei
jahren in denen staat und gesellschaft
sich im wesentlichen um die bekämpfung
der pandemie kümmern und wir alle
erleben dass und erfahren dass wenn wir
mit menschen in unseren wahlkreisen
sprechen die menschen sind der pandemie
müde die menschen sind den maßnahmen
gegen die pandemie müde und das führt zu
verdruss und das führt zu einer großen
enttäuschung
und wir müssen es hinbekommen und wir
müssen dafür stehen als alle
demokratischen kräfte in diesem haus
dass diejenigen die diesen verdruss und
die diese enttäuschung für ihre
extremistische agenda nutzen wollen
damit keinen erfolg haben können weil
damit denn der journalisten angreift wer
wissenschaftler angreift wer
kommunalpolitiker angreift wer
ehrenamtliche helfer im impfzentrum
angreift der macht nicht von seiner
meinungsfreiheit gebrauch sondern
übergeht straftaten und diese straftaten
müssen hart bestraft werden und deswegen
steht diese neue koalition bei ihrer
arbeit an der seite der
sicherheitsbehörden und sie wird die
wichtige und die gute arbeit der
sicherheitsbehörden ergänzen um neue
schwerpunkte und dazu gehört die
demokratie förderung dazu gehört die
extremismus prävention denn beides ist
in den letzten jahren zu kurz gekommen
und ich bin ihnen liebe frau
bundesinnenministerium auch dankbar dass
sie ganz klar gemacht haben mit blick
auf den koalitionsvertrag diese ampel
koalition sie grenzt sich ab und sie
bekämpft alle formen des gewaltbereiten
extremismus angefangen vom
rechtsextremismus als besondere
herausforderung über den islamismus
dessen besondere bedrohung den nicht
vernachlässigen dürfen über den
linksextremismus und die verschwörungs
ideologien die der momentan allerorts
beobachten können meine damen und herren
ich will die heutige debatte aber auch
nutzen um dem ehemaligen
bundesinnenminister seehofer für seine
arbeit zu danken ich weiß gar nicht ob
er uns heute dazu schaut es gab ja
zwischen fdp und horst seehofer durchaus
auch mal unterschiedliche meinungen fest
steht wir wünschen ihm alles gute für
den wohlverdienten ruhestand wenn nicht
mehr die debattenbeiträge aus der union
in der heutigen debatte aber so
anschauen muss ich sagen es ist auch
ganz gut dass die union nach 16 jahren
nicht mehr die verantwortung für die
innenpolitik auf bundesebene treten und
das sieht man an keinem thema so sehr
wie an der integrationspolitik was da an
vorschlägen kommt ist doch in wahrheit
eine einwanderungspolitik aus dem
letzten jahrtausend eine
migrationspolitik im sinne und im
interesse unseres landes weniger
irreguläre migration und mehr reguläre
migration war und ist offenbar mit der
union nicht möglich in puncto irreguläre
migration liegt das daran dass sie die
eu ratspräsidentschaft nicht genutzt
haben um beim gemeinsamen europäischen
asylsystems voranzukommen und es liegt
daran dass sie die länder eben nicht
unterstützen bei rückführungen von
straftätern und gefährdern sie müssen
sich ja nur anschauen ich weiß gar nicht
warum sie mit dem kopf schütteln welches
land bei der rückführung von straftätern
und gefährder in deutschland am
erfolgreichsten ist das ist nordrhein
westfalen das sollten sie den
regierungseintritt der fdp auf
bundesebene eigentlich beklatschen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der union
wenn sie ihnen die abschiebung von
straftätern und gefährdern am herzen
liegt denn da machen wir das und bei der
regulären migration werden wir durch ein
einwanderungsgesetz mit punktesystemen
endlich dazu beitragen dass es zum
nötigen
wechsel in deutschland kommt und dass
wir mit der lebenslüge der union schluss
machen dass deutschland kein
einwanderungsland ist deutschland ist
ein einwanderungsland und bei der
ausgestaltung deutschland als
einwanderungsland machen wir auch vor
dem staatsangehörigkeitsrecht nicht halt
meine damen und herren eine letzte kurze
bemerkung wenn unsere
sicherheitsbehörden und der staat die
bürgerinnen und bürger verteidigen und
beschützen vor kriminalität vor gewalt
vor extremismus dann schützen sie unsere
rechtsordnung zu dieser rechtsordnung
gehören der schutz von leib leben und
eigentum zu dieser rechtsordnung gehört
aber auch das recht auf privatsphäre
auch vertraulichkeit der kommunikation
auf informationelle selbstbestimmung und
auch hier wird die neue koalition einen
paradigmenwechsel einleiten weil uns die
bürgerlichen freiheitsrechte besonders
am herzen liegen deswegen kommt die
überwachungs gesamtrechnung deswegen
kommt der periodische sicherheitsbericht
deswegen kommt die freiheits kommission
und deswegen ist diese koalition der
sicherheit verpflichtet aber sie dient
der freiheit in diesem sinne freue ich
mich auf viele im netz polizeiwachen in
der neuen amtsperiode und duschen erfolg
mit windows im nächsten danke
der bundestag debattiert in verbundener
debatte zur politik der bundesregierung
über im bereich innen und heimat und
martina renner die sprecherin für
antifaschistische politik der linken hat
jetzt das hot
kolleginnen und kollegen der
demokratischen fraktion
wir vernehmen tatsächlich neue töne aus
dem innenministerium
auch heute und
insbesondere zum kampf gegen rechts in
der vergangenheit wurden rechte
netzwerke rechter terror verdrängt
verharmlost und verkauft bei ihnen im
koalitionsvertrag heißt es jetzt
rechtsextremismus ist derzeit die größte
bedrohung unserer demokratie
und frau innenministerin feser sie haben
es sollte ja auch wiederholt ich nehme
sie wirklich sehr gerne beim wort an
diesem punkt
beim wort nehmen das muss heißen wir
erwarten von der bundesregierung dass
endlich nicht nur geredet sondern
wirksame maßnahmen ergriffen werden um
rechte gewalt und rechten terror zu
stoppen das heißt entwaffnen sie die
rechte szene verhaftet
verhaftet sie untergetauchte neonazis
schmeißen sie rassisten und antisemiten
aus dem polizeidienst und das muss
schnell passieren
und nehmen sie abschied vom extremismus
begriff der nur vernebelt und die
geheimdienste legitimiert
aber das allerwichtigste
hören sie mich darf bei ihnen sagen
hören sie auch weiterhin den bedrohten
menschen zu die opferperspektive sie
fehlte bisher im innenminister
[Applaus]
eine weitere last aus dem seehofer
ministerium ist das auf
sicherheitsbedrohungen immer mit dem ruf
nach mehr technik nach mehr überwachung
und nach mehr eingriffen und grund und
freiheitsrechte reagiert wurden ihre
koalitionsvertrag klingt das schon
anders
entscheidend wird jedoch sein ob sie
tatsächlich so gefährliche tools wie die
spionagesoftware pegasus den behörden
aus der hand nehmen
beenden sie die diskriminierenden
anlasslosen kontrollen der bundespolizei
sorgen sie dafür dass polizeiliche
datenbanken sicher sind und menschen
nicht grundlos in ihnen gespeichert
werden und binden sie den eigenen
datenschutzbeauftragten mit seinen
bedenken auch in ihrer arbeit reisen
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
der demokratischen fraktion über genau
an diesem punkt muss man ist glaube ich
noch mal sagen
der letzte innenminister er hat menschen
im mittelmeer ertrinken lassen
das ist eine unverschämtheit ergebnis
seiner politik gewesen
und und er hat seine zustimmung zur
aufnahme von geflüchteten durch die
bundesländer verweigert obwohl diese
dazu bereit waren sie wollen das leid an
den außengrenzen stoppen das steht im
koalitionsvertrag
wenn sie es ernst meinen dann handeln
sie jetzt und zwar sofort
an den außengrenzen wird jeden tag
gestorben das ist kein thema was wir in
einem halben jahr behandeln sollten
setzen sie sich jetzt für sichere
fluchtwege 1 stoppen sie die illegale
praxis und die militarisierung von
frontex und teilen sie die länder das
einvernehmen wenn diese landes
aufnahmeprogramme für schutzsuchende
vorlegen und das sage ich ihnen auch als
theorien wir wollen aus thüringen hier
ein signal aus dem innenministerium
rensing oder das glaube ich wirklich
besser sein wollen als ihr vorgänger
dann hören sie auf das was wissenschaft
zivilgesellschaft und engagierte ihnen
sagen hören sie vielleicht mal ein
bisschen weniger auf die spitzenbeamten
die sie von seehofer übernommen haben
belasten sie es nicht mit den schönen
oft auch richtigen ansagen werden sie
konkret vielen dank
auf jeden fall nicht so eine aggressive
die von der cdu
das wort hat der kollege dirk wiese für
die spd
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrte frau
bundesministerin ich bin ihnen sehr
dankbar ich bin ihnen dankbar dafür dass
sie in ihrer rede sehr klar gesagt haben
dass wir uns als ampelkoalition jeder
form des extremismus in unserem land
klar entgegenstellen wir haben das im
koalitionsvertrag deutlich nieder
geschrieben wir stellen uns allen
verfassungsfeinden gewaltbereiten
bestrebungen und verschwörungs
ideologien entgegen und das sage ich
auch nach draußen die ist kein platz für
extremismus in diesem land
begrüße es ausdrücklich dass sie sehr
klar gesagt haben dass die bekämpfung
des rechtsextremismus
aktuell die größte gefährdung für dieses
land ist ich bin dankbar dass sie gesagt
haben ein dass sie einen kurzfristigen
aktionsplan im kampf gegen rechts
vorlegen ich möchte aber auch sagen dass
ich es ausdrücklich begrüße dass sie
klar gesagt haben dass das demokratie
fördergesetz eines der hauptanliegen
dieser bundesregierung wird denn das
demokratie fördergesetz ich will das
doch mal sagen ist entscheidend die
demokratie wird angegriffen von
unterschiedlichen seiten sie wird in
frage gestellt und es gibt so viele
akteure in diesem land die jeden tag für
die demokratie streiten die sich für die
demokratie einsetzen und diese
initiativen dieses engagement die gilt
es zu stärken und ich will noch mal eins
deutlich sagen ich bin dem scheidenden
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer zu
dank verpflichtet denn wir hatten in der
letzten bundesregierung eine einigung
hinbekommen in der bundesregierung für
eine demokratie fördergesetz wie als
spd-bundestagsfraktion wollten das noch
verabschieden und es war die fraktion
der cdu/csu wollen sie im kampf gegen
rechts an dieser stelle versagt hat und
es ist eine amnesie dass sie sich daran
nicht mehr erinnert wird
begrüße es ausdrücklich dass wir gegen
telegramm vorankommen wollen denn es
kann nicht sein dass dort ungehindert
morddrohungen geschrieben werden
bedrohungen ausgesprochen werden das
kann nicht sein und ich finde es auch
absolut richtig dass wir klar uns dazu
bekannt haben im koalitionsvertrag auch
verfassungsfeinde aus dem öffentlichen
dienst leichter zu entfernen wer nicht
auf dem boden des grundgesetzes steht
wenn nach 17 uhr die freiheitliche
demokratische grundordnung angreift der
kann nicht im öffentlichen dienst
beschäftigt sein das sage ich auch an
dieser stelle sehr deutlich
mein dank gilt aktuell den vielen
polizistinnen und polizisten die
aktuellen unterwegs sind die ja momentan
gerade in der aktuellen situation kaum
man sagt es aus den stiefeln rauskommen
und ich glaube wir müssen gerade für die
bundespolizei erneut den einsatzwagen
ein modernes bundespolizei gesetz auf
den weg zu bringen wir haben uns ganz
klar dazu bekannt dass das bundespolizei
gesetzt die letzte reform war aus dem
jahr 1994 dass wir das jetzt auf den
grund auf den weg bringen das ist
anerkennung für die arbeit der
bundespolizei und ebenfalls anerkennung
für die arbeit der bundespolizei ist es
die ruhegehalts fähigkeit der polizei
zulage ein entscheidendes thema wir
werden das ampel koalition gemeinsam
voranbringen
lassen sie mich aus führen dass ihnen
das thema der inneren sicherheit nicht
immer nur einseitig auf repression
gerichtet ist es ist genauso wichtig
auch immer wieder zu fragen warum kommt
es zur kriminalität warum kommt es zur
sicherheits verstößen warum letztendlich
was sind die ursachen dafür und da
werden wir auch innerhalb dieser ampel
koalition ein schwerpunkt darauf setzen
die prävention gerade auch zu stärken
dass es erst gar nicht zur kriminalität
kommt dass es erst gar nicht dazu kommt
dass sich kriminalität entwickelt das
sich extremismus entwickeln kann und das
ist glaube ich einer der entscheidenden
punkte diesen präventionsgedanken auch
zu stärken voranzubringen ganz im sinne
vielleicht wie es einmal tony blair
gesagt hat law and order ist albers
liebe kolleginnen und kolleginnen lassen
sie mich vielleicht zum abschluss auch
noch einen weiteren wichtigen
zuständigkeitsbereich des
bundesinnenministeriums auch noch mal
hervorheben und das ist die gesamte
bereich des sports ich bin etwas
überrascht dass die vorrednerin der
fraktion die linke frau rena kein wort
zum sport verloren hat ist für mich
etwas überraschend an dieser stelle bei
der schwerpunktsetzung ich will aber
noch einmal sehr deutlich aus führen der
sport ist wichtig und der sport gerade
auch der spitzenverband sport verdient
letztendlich auch die unterstützung es
ist gut dass sich der dsb glaube ich
auch neu aufgestellt hat es ist gut dass
wir die unterstützung für den sport auch
im rahmen der korona hilfen verlängern
den sport hier weiter unterstützen und
es ist auch richtig dass wir als
ampelkoalition klar gesagt haben wir
wollen sportstätten wir wollen die
sportinfrastruktur wir wollen die
schwimmbäder in den kommunen in den
kreisen der tüchtige da wird integration
gelebt in den sportverein da ist
gelebtes ehrenamt und das wollen wir
gemeinsam voranbringen und das werden
wir auch als ampel koalition gemeinsam
mit dem bundesinnenministerium auf den
weg bringen
das sind nämlich zum schluss kommen und
vielleicht mit einem zitat schließen was
vielleicht dem einen oder anderen
vorredner vielleicht mal das eine oder
andere nachdenken bereitet helmut
schmidt hat einen wichtigen satz gesagt
wer die vergangenheit nicht studiert der
wird ihre irrtümer nicht wiederhole das
gilt hier im plenum aber besonders auf
der tribüne vielen dank
diese der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der spd ich hatte
eigentlich erwartet dass er etwas zu der
äußerungen von herrn kohl helmut schmidt
sagt der ehemalige bundeskanzler ist tot
kann sich nicht mehr wehren aber die
chance hat er ausgelassen
ignorieren das ist das motto der nächste
redner kommt jetzt von der cdu alexander
ich wünsche ihnen zunächst bei ihrer
schwierigen verantwortungsvollen aufgabe
alles gute erfolg und auch das
notwendige glück im interesse unseres
landes
frau ministerin sie haben am anfang
ihrer ernennung gesagt sicherheit ist
eine frage sozialer gerechtigkeit ja und
diesen satz kann ich voll und ganz
unterstreichen nur leider findet sich
von diesem satz in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag relativ wenig in
deutschland ja braucht fachkräfte
zuwanderung
es lässt aber aufhorchen dass sieben
koalitionsvertrag allgemein von
arbeitskräfte einwanderungen sprechen
und er passt dazu dass sie die hürden
für die anerkennung von
berufsabschlüssen
herabsenken wollen das ist nichts
anderes als ein absenken der
qualifikation sie wollen die
gleichwertigkeit der berufsabschlüsse
wie sie im fachkräfte
einwanderungsgesetz steht schleifen und
das ist nicht sozial weil es unfairer
wettbewerb um die arbeitsplätze bedeutet
und bei geringer qualifikation ein
höheres risiko für die einwand und die
sozialsysteme bedeuten
bei fachkräften
geht es um die menschen die wir brauchen
die unsere wirtschaft braucht bei flucht
und asyl geht es um menschen die uns die
unseren schutz brauchen diese
unterscheidung ist keine banalität es
ist die entscheidende vielleicht sogar
die einzige weichenstellung die wir
tatsächlich haben für die steuerung und
die begrenzung illegaler migration und
genau dieses steuerungsinstrument
das wollen sie von der ampel auf geben
indem sie einen allgemeinen spurwechsel
einfügen zusammen mit anderen vorhaben
ausweitung des familiennachzugs
ausweitung der asylbewerber und
gesundheitsleistungen vieles andere
schaffen sie weitere anreize nach
deutschland zu kommen insbesondere im
rahmen der sekundär migration wir sind
heute schon das land in der gesamten
westlichen welt das bezogen auf seine
bevölkerung die meisten flüchtlinge
aufnimmt sie verstärken dies noch und
das bedeutet mehr soziale spannungen und
weniger soziale gerechtigkeit
und ja sie schreiben im
koalitionsvertrag ihr ziel sei ein
paradigmenwechsel hin zu einem modernen
einwanderungsland und mich stört dabei
keineswegs der begriff einwanderungsland
ja das sind wir faktischen bei den
fachkräfte wollen wir das auch aber was
nicht heißt ist das attribut nein es
kein wandel was nicht passt ist das
attribut moderne herr kollege coole weil
sie haben den anschluss verpasst alle
anderen europäischen länder rennen
nämlich in eine andere richtung als sie
von der ampel das vorhaben der dänische
minister
ein sozialdemokrat sagt offene grenzen
und sozialer wohlfahrt start passen
nicht zusammen die länder europas alle
egal welcher couleur schweden österreich
frankreich dänemark alle haben seit 2015
ihre migrations gesetzgebung
restriktiver ausgeschaltet sie wollen
einen paradigmenwechsel in die
vergangenheit das bedeutet ein
rückschritt nicht das was unsere
vorstellungen waren wie die politik der
letzten jahre war herr kollege kunden
und
sie führen das auch ford in ganz anderen
bereichen beispielsweise
im bereich der
personen mit ungeklärter identität das
sind sie bereit ihre ideologie sogar
sicherheitsinteressen unterzuordnen
indem sie beispielsweise den personen
die auch ihren pass weggeworfen haben
oder sonst wie die identität nicht
geklärt ist die möglichkeit geben eine
eidesstattliche erklärung abzugeben ich
glaube dass ihn viele anwälte frau
ministerin wir beide sind rechtsanwälte
und ich denke wir wissen und die
begrenzte beweiskraft einer
eidesstattlichen erklärung und deswegen
ist dieses vorhaben bestenfalls naiv
aber eher eine realitätsverweigerung in
ihrem koalitionsvertrag das ist nicht
sozial das ist gefährlich und
sie schreiben dann bei der sicherheit
deutschland ist eines der sichersten
länder dieser welt danke ja so ist es
wir nehmen dies als kompliment an wir
haben die letzten jahre die
verantwortung für die sicherheit in
deutschland maßgeblich getragen und wir
haben alles dafür getan um die
sicherheitsbehörden mit personal
ausreichend auszustatten und auch
ansonsten gut zu versorgen eben auch mit
rechtlichen befugnissen wir haben
gebohrt bei unseren koalitionspartnern
zuletzt der spd einige maßnahmen
abgerungen in dieser koalition dort
niemand mehr in dieser koalition wird
nicht gelungen alle sind sich einig der
ganze koalitionsvertrag brief geradezu
vor misstrauen gegenüber den
sicherheitsbehörden den polizistinnen
und polizisten
liebe kollegen vor es gibt mehr
kontrolle es gibt mehr kontrolle ja nur
nicht bei den kriminellen und bei den
tätern sondern bei unserer polizei
polizei beauftragte kennzeichnung der
datenschutz mehr restriktionen weniger
vertrauen das ist ein koalitionsvertrag
der nicht das vertrauen gegenüber den
polizisten polizisten ausspricht im
gegenteil sie legen der polizei fesseln
an und das ist nicht sicher frau
ministerin sicherheit ist eine frage der
sozialen gerechtigkeit aber es ist auch
ein grundbedürfnis aller menschen sie
sind dafür verantwortlich deswegen meine
bitte hören sie auf ihr haus hören sie
auf ihre fachleute in den einzelnen
behörden forderungen für mehr befugnisse
in der inneren sicherheit kommen dort
von den menschen die sich darum sorgen
machen ihnen wünsche ich dass sie den
mut haben die hessen die ihnen der
koalitionsvertrag anlegt abzulösen das
sehen dann
alexander throm der neue sprecher für
innen und heimat politik der cdu csu
sein
was jetzt emmerich ist im mitglied im
ausschuss innere heimat inneres und
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir erleben in den letzten monat letzten
monaten verstärkt dass versucht wird
unseren staat seinen institutionen und
unsere gesellschaft zu spalten und zu
verhöhnen mit verschwörungs mythen
antidemokratischen und anti
wissenschaftlichen parolen verbreitet
werden und ich möchte jetzt die
gelegenheit nutzen mal ein signal der
solidarität auszusenden an all
diejenigen die da draußen die direkt
davon betroffen sind es gibt nicht ganz
viele menschen die sich tagtäglich dafür
einsetzen ärztinnen wissenschaftler in
den journalistinnen viele
kommunalpolitiker in die die sich jeden
tag für unser gemeinwohl einsetzen und
von diesen angriffen ja betroffen sind
und das ist mir ganz wichtig war auch
bei mir in meinem wahlkreis in ulm ist
er dekan ernst-wilhelm gohl davon
betroffen er hat in seinem in seiner
kirche eine infektion durchführen lassen
und wird seitdem mit drohbriefen
überfrachtet und sie alle hier in den
reihen haben auch solche beispiele bei
sich von irgendwelchen landrätinnen oder
von anderen engagierten personen
deswegen ist es mir wichtig dass wir ja
auch als parlament verantwortung
übernehmen und ein signal aussenden
diese menschen verdienen unsere
unterstützung
unserer respekt und unsere anerkennung
für ihre arbeit vielen dank für ihr
engagement vielen dank
und ich bin sehr froh frau ministerin
und ich muss sagen dass wir wirklich
sehr wohltuend ihre worte hier das war
wirklich wie in einer richtigen neuen
zeit ihre worte hier redepult das kannte
man von ihrem vorgänger so nicht und das
zeigt einfach dass wir hier eine andere
innenpolitik in zukunft haben werden ich
will mich auch bedanken dass sie das
noch mal so stark hervorgehoben haben
was wir in der koalition vereinbart
haben beim thema rechtsextremismus was
sie auch gesagt haben das ist eine
besondere priorität für uns hat
demokratie fördergesetz und auch die
frage der weiteren aufarbeitung und den
offenen fragen warum endes so komplex
und ihre ankündigung eines aktionsplans
gegen rechtsextremismus dass es was da
haben sie die volle unterstützung meiner
fraktion wir freuen uns auf die
mitarbeit bei diesen themen mit
einem klaren kompass für freiheit
sicherheit unter demokratischen
rechtsstaat gestalten hier dieses land
also neu wir werden nicht alle probleme
auf einmal lösen aber wir gehen weg von
ford werden den impulsiven rufen nach
weiteren gesetzesverschärfungen und
stehen stattdessen ein für eine
vorausschauende
evidenzbasierte und vor allem
grundrechts orientierten politik dazu
dazu gehörte periodische sicherheits
wirklich dazu gehört eine überwachungs
gesamtrechnung gelassen ab von der
anlasslosen vorratsdatenspeicherung und
wir schränken die quellen-tkü 1 damit
stärken wir im übrigen auch die
it-sicherheit in diesem und angesichts
vieler weiterer datenlecks ist das auch
wirklich sehr sehr wichtig für die
sicherheit in unserem land sorgen jeden
tag über 300.000 polizistin vielen dank
für ihre arbeit wir starten sie besser
aus mit sachmitteln und wir stehen an
ihrer seite und sorgen dafür dass sie
mehr kolleginnen an ihrer seite haben
mit der einführung einer unabhängigen
polizei beauftragten schaffen wir mehr
bürgerinnen und eine anlaufstelle
innerhalb der polizei wir stellen
außerdem den bevölkerungsschutz in
zukunft neu auf und wir sorgen für mehr
mitbestimmung bürgerinnenbeteiligung und
transparenz das ist auch ein neuer
politikansatz ein neuer politikstil
meine damen und herren wir haben auch
heute gehört was uns über der frage von
migration asyl und flüchtlingspolitik in
den nächsten jahren als opposition von
dieser seite
ja dass wir da zu hören bekommen vor
allem angstmacherei beide fragen von
geflüchteten bei verwendet um oder wenn
es um migrantinnen geht wir machen hier
auch einen aufbruch einen neuanfang
statt ausgrenzung abschottung stellen
wir endlich wieder menschlichkeit und
mitgefühl in den vordergrund für eine
vielfältige gesellschaft das heißt wir
kommen weg von kettenduldungen
stattdessen echte perspektiven und auch
ganz klares jahr zu sehen und der ton
dazu stehen wir auf europäischer ebene
deutschland ist natürlich ein
einwanderungsland wer anderes sagt liegt
vollkommen falsch und das muss sich
jetzt aber auch endlich in gesetzlichen
rahmenbedingungen widerspiegeln und
dafür sorgen wir mit einem modernen
staatsangehörigkeitsrecht ermöglichen
wir nach mehr als 20 jahren nach der
unsäglichen doppelpass kampagne mit der
mehrstaatigkeit endlich die einbürgerung
für alle mit einem punktesystem
will ein punktesystem schaffen wir ein
modernes und gerechtes
einwanderungsgesetz unsere politik ist
klar egal welche sprachen jemand spricht
wie jemand aussieht wo jemand herkommt
oder welches geschlecht jemand hat jede
und jeder hat das recht sicher in
freiheit und würde und ohne angst zu
leben
daran konstruktiv mitzuarbeiten dazu
laden wir alle demokratischen fraktionen
ein ich freue mich auf die
zusammenarbeit vor allem im ausschuss
ich setze mich dafür ein vielen dank für
ihre aufmerksamkeit
marcel emmerich war das von den
bündnisgrünen einer der vielen neuen
bundestagsabgeordneten heute hier bei
dieser debatte des bundestags von innen
und heimat ressort mit seiner ersten
rede seine erste rede als
innenpolitischer sprecher der fdp hält
heute manuel höferlin
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten kolleginnen und kollegen mit
der fortschritts koalition stehen wir in
deutschland vor einer wende in der
politik und das hat liebe frau
bundesministerin fehse ich finde ihre
rede auch gezeigt ich freue mich auf die
zusammenarbeit mit ihnen und ihrem haus
in diesem bündnis steht auch nicht
umsonst freiheit ganz vorne übrigens
auch in der bezeichnung des
koalitionsvertrags nirgendwo wird das
deutlich so deutlich wie der
innenpolitik dass diese wende so nötig
ist und in den letzten jahren ist sie
die innenpolitik auch aus dem
gleichgewicht geraten zu lange wurde
zwischen freiheit und sicherheit
einseitig abgewogen viel zu häufig
zulasten der freiheit und damit ist
jetzt schluss
damit
dabei gilt hier die
weisheit freiheit ist nicht alles aber
ohne
freiheit ist alles nichts und die ziele
von innenpolitik sind immer freiheit und
sicherheit aber nicht wie bei der union
wie man auch im rhein rufen gleich
wieder merkt sicherheit vor und gegen
die menschen sondern eben wie mit der
fortschritts koalition sicherheit für
und mit den menschen meine damen
entfernen denn wo in den letzten jahren
ein freiheits und grundrechtseingriff
nach dem anderen veranlasst wurde setzt
die fortschritts koalition eine
freiheits kommission ein wo in den
letzten jahren einen überwachungs gesetz
nach dem anderen gelassen wurde wird die
fortschritts koalition eine überwachungs
gesamtrechnung vornehmen und die
bürgerrechte analog wie digital wieder
achten wo sicherheitslücken für
staatliches spitzeln offen gehalten
wurden etabliert die fortschritts
koalition echtes
schwachstellenmanagement um
sicherheitslücken zu schließen wo
vertrauliche kommunikation ein dorn im
auge war schafft die freiheits position
ein recht auf verschlüsselung
wovon vor fahrlässig sicherheit
untergraben wurde sorgt die fortschritts
koalition für eine stärkung in dem
wieder rechtssicher schwachstellen
aufgespürt werden können ohne sich
strafbar zu machen wo keine sinnvolle
idee mit dem umgang von daten entstand
wird die fortschritts koalition die
potenziale von daten heben
beispielsweise durch daten drehscheiben
und wir werden auch den datenschutz
besser organisieren dort rot zu wenig
polizistinnen und polizisten die
notwendigen daten abgleichen dienst
hilfsweise mit ihren privaten
mobilfunkgeräten vornehmen mussten dort
sorgt die fortschritts koalition für
anständige ausrüstung und mehr personal
dort wo ein wir schaffen das zum konzept
erhoben wurde dort bringt die
fortschritts koalition die migrations
und integrationspolitik auf die höhe der
zeit eines modernen einwanderungslandes
und dort wo entscheidungen hinter
verschlossenen türen getroffen worden
dort stärkt die fortschritts koalition
das parlament hier als ort debatte der
debatte und der gesetzgebung eine lounge
haben
und lassen sie mir lassen sie mir eine
anmerkung wir respektieren und schätzen
ausdrücklich die arbeit einer
konstruktiven opposition und liebe
freunde der union lassen sie mich zu
sagen
für unsere fraktion der weise für die
ganze koalition wir werden sie genauso
behandeln wie sie dies in den letzten
jahren mit uns getan habe meine damen
und herren
sondern zu sagen das zeigt deutlich
meinen und herren wir
brauchen mehr fortschritt und freiheit
wir wollen dass wagen auch in der
innenpolitik ist es dringend notwendig
deshalb sorgen wir dafür dass die
innenpolitik endlich im 21 jahrhundert
ankommt und nicht verbleibt wo sie
hinterlassen haben das wieder lust am
fortschritt geschieht statt angst vor
der eigenen courage das wieder den
menschen gedient wird auch in der
innenpolitik und zwar in ihrer freiheit
und ihrer sicherheit gleichermaßen das
ist unser auftrag den wir erhalten haben
den sind wir verpflichtet und diesen
auftrag werden wir auch erfüllen
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat der kollege detlef seif für
die cdu/csu frau zu
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren
mein wahlkreis euskirchen rhein erft 2
ist von der jüngsten flutkatastrophe
besonders schwer betroffen alle akteure
des katastrophenschutzes
namentlich die mitarbeiter der kommunen
die feuerwehren die hilfsorganisation
das thw aber auch bundeswehr und
landespolizei sowie bundespolizei haben
hier einen wirklich tollen job gemacht
dazu kommt das engagement der vielen
spontan helfenden aus nah und fern
vielen dank für ihren einsatz
zu beeindrucken der einsatz aber war so
deutlich sind hier aber auch im gesamten
verlauf der pandemie
die strukturen unseres
bevölkerungsschutzes zu tage getragen
getragen denn hier müssen deutliche
verbesserungen vollzogen werden der
bevölkerungsschutz liegt nicht in der in
einer hand der bund ist zuständig für
den schutz der bevölkerung vorkriegs
gefahren dem sogenannten zivilschutz und
die länder und ihre kommunen tragen die
hauptverantwortung für den
katastrophenschutz in der praxis führt
dies bei großschadenslagen insbesondere
bei länderübergreifenden krisen zu
mitunter
kraftraubenden parallelstrukturen trägen
informationsflüssen und mehrstimmigkeit
deshalb ist nicht die frage ob die
strukturen verändert werden müssen
sondern wie ein wichtiger schritt ist
die einrichtung des gemeinsamen
kompetenzzentrums beim bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz bbk bund und länder
sind sich einig das soll ein zentraler
dreh- und angelpunkt werden auch für die
bereitstellung eines jederzeit
verfügbaren 360° lagebildes meine damen
und herren die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
fordert die bundesregierung auf die
voraussetzungen für dieses gemeinsame
kompetent zentrum möglichst schnell zu
schaffen die qualität des
bevölkerungsschutzes darf jedenfalls
nicht an den gesetzlichen strukturen
oder zuständigkeiten scheitern
eigentlich wollte ich an der stelle
jetzt noch weitere ausführungen zur
stärkung des bevölkerungsschutzes machen
aber ich bearbeite seit jahren asyl und
migration und da zunächst per curio um
in ihren worten mal zu bleiben sie sind
ein kommunikativer messerstecher und
terroristen ich weiß nicht ob sie merken
dass das was sie hier ins land streuen
ein vergiftetes klima produziert sie
sind brandstifter für das was andere
nachher mit messern und pistolen
ausführen das ist das schlimme an ihrem
beitrag
warum noch zwei sätze zu sagen was hier
zu asyl migration gesagt wurde der
humanitäre einsatz ist hier richtig frau
bundesinnenministerium aber wir hatten
2015 die erfahrung gemacht deutschland
darf nicht den fehler machen jetzt große
pool effekte zu erzeugen es geht nicht
nur um eine million menschen die zu uns
kommen wollen es geht um viele millionen
menschen aus dieser welt die kommen
würden schaffen sie keine perfekte
machen sie nicht den fehler dass die
situation von 2015 sich noch verschärft
der richtige weg ist vollendung des
gemeinsamen europäischen asylsystems
prüfung an den außengrenzen screening
die leute erfassen und wirklich korrekt
vorgehen und im einzelfall das wollte
ich ihn mit auf den weg gehen der
humanitäre einsatz die
herzensangelegenheit ist angekommen aber
sie haben auch verantwortung für dieses
land und die menschen und wenn sie hier
falsch handeln dann geben sie der afb
dann geben sie den rechtsradikalen
nahrung und das müssen wir vermeiden das
ist zusätzliches gift gegen den
zusammenhalt in der gesellschaft vielen
dank
zum einen kollegen haben sie jetzt
begonnen auf kosten ihres nachfolgenden
kollegen zu sprechen und zweitens
bitte ich sie sich zu mäßigen wenn es um
die bezeichnung oder charakterisierung
von anderen abgeordneten geht das heißt
sich einer parlamentarischen
ausdrucksweise befleißigt
das wort hat nun der kollege stefan
zeidler der
fang seidler ist fraktionslos erst das
einzige mitglied des südschleswigschen
wählerverbandes die seit 70 jahren das
erste mal wieder im deutschen bundestag
sitzen
frau bundesministerin sie haben erklärt
dass sie den kampf gegen den
rechtsextremismus
und für den gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt im mittelpunkt ihrer arbeit
stellen möchten das begrüße ich und sage
wir müssen uns
rechtsextremismus gegenüber wären aber
wissen sie
was ich derzeit erlebe in meiner heimat
ist das echte kräfte versuchen regionale
tradition in deutschland für sich zu
vereinnahmen
kulturgruppen und volksgruppen ja zu
umgarnen oder sie umgarnen sie und auf
diese art und weise die vielfalt
einzuschränken und doch ist es ja gerade
diese vielfalt dieser verschiedenen
kulturen und minderheiten die auch unser
land und unsere heimat ausbrachen
extremismus gedeiht dort wo keiner sich
kümmert und strukturschwäche und
hoffnungslosigkeit sich breit macht und
daran müssen wir besonders in der
peripherie und in den ländlichen räumen
diese aus stärken dies sind oft gebiete
in denen eben gerade nationale
minderheiten und volksgruppen heimisch
sind und deshalb meine klare
aufforderung an sie und an das gesamte
parlament lassen sie uns die rechte und
die position von heimischen minderheiten
im grundgesetz verankert so wie es
bereits in vielen landesverfassungen der
fall ist sorgen sie dafür dass die
kulturellen einrichtungen und die
schulen der nationalen minderheiten und
der volksgruppen dauerhaft finanziert
und besser gefördert werden und nicht
auf sich allein gestellt sind denn der
kampf für den gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt der muss zwingend auch
unserem unterhalten hier im lande mit
einschließen vielen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat der kollege stephan mayer
für die cdu csu fort
frau präsidentin meine lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen zunächst möchte
ich ihnen liebe frau bundesministerin
feser für ihre eminent wichtige und auch
anspruchsvolle aufgabe alles erdenklich
gute und glückliches händchen und auch
gottes segen wünschen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren ich fand es
kollege dr hahn hat schon darauf
hingewiesen auch bemerkenswert dass sie
besser aber in ihren ausführungen einer
der wichtigsten gesellschaftspolitischen
bewegungen in unserem land dem sport
kaum eine silbe gewidmet haben und mit
verlaub da reicht es auch nicht wird zu
erwähnen dass man nicht zu den
olympischen winterspielen reisen wird
der sport ist mit über 90.000 vereinen
in deutschland einer der wichtigsten
schätze den wir haben eine die eine der
wichtigsten wenn nicht sogar die
wichtigste gesellschaftliche bewegung
wir haben über 27 millionen
mitgliedschaften in den über 90.000
sportvereinen 8 millionen mitbürger
mitbürger engagieren sich tagtäglich
ehrenamtlich im sport und da muss ich
ganz ehrlich sein da finde ich es nicht
nur bemerkenswerter sie frau
bundesministerin dem sport hier keine
erwähnung schenken sondern dass auch im
koalitionsvertrag gerade mal von 177
seiten eine seite auch den sport
entfällt und wenn ich mir diese seite
durch lesen dann muss ich mit verlaub
sagen dann sind die ausführungen sehr
sehr vage und ambitiös und nichts haben
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren in
diesem in dies auf dieser einen seite
werden keine ausführungen dazu gemacht
wie wir dem wichtigen thema stärkung des
ehrenamtes mehr bedeutung beimessen
wollen was wir unternehmen wollen um
ehrenamtliches engagement im sport zu
erleichtern wir insbesondere den über
90.000 sportvereine aus der korona
pandemie in der korona pandemie
unterstützen wollen und hier sieht wie
wir sie dann im neustart auch wieder
antreiben und unterstützen wollen all
diese ausführungen fehlen es ist keine
es wird keine ausführung vorgenommen zum
thema des behindertensport es ganz
wichtig die er das thema der inklusion
von menschen mit behinderung durch und
im sport auch dem thema
gesundheitsprävention gesundheitliche
vorsorge durch den sport und im sport
wird keine silbe im koalitionsvertrag
gewidmet das ist aus meiner sicht
wirklich sehr sehr dünn ist rose
vielmehr tauchen nur allgemeinplätze auf
die nichtssagend sind auch dem thema
stärkung des leistungssportlers wird
keine bemerkung geschenkt es wird nicht
darauf hingewiesen was wir tun müssen um
deutschland wieder gerade auch im
sommersport zu einem der erfolgreichsten
sportler der sportler regeln
ich habe die redezeit angehalten ich
habe muss nur identifizieren wer gerade
die frage stellen würde
gestatten sie eine frage von bemerken
ausgezogen bündnis 90 die grünen
vielen dank herr kollege meyer dass die
zwischenfrage zu lassen vor dem
hintergrund dass sie sich gerade darüber
echauffiert haben das in unserem
koalitionsvertrag für sich eine seite
dem sport widmet hätten sie die güte dem
plenum zu erklären wie viele seiten denn
im koalitionsvertrag
2017 wo ja ihr parteifreund herr
seehofer dann für den sport zuständig
war denn sich mit dem sport beschäftigt
haben
danke ihnen sehr für diese frage weil
sie mir die gelegenheit gibt durchaus
auch noch mal etwas ausführlicher darauf
hinzuweisen dass die letzte
legislaturperiode für den sport eine
wenn nicht sogar die erfolgreichste
legislaturperiode zeit bestehende und
natürlich deutschland war wissen sie was
wir geschafft haben und für mich dafür
entscheiden wie viele wie viele seiten
der sport umfasst hat im letzten jahr
die chance vergab wissen sie was wir
geschafft haben wir haben im winter für
die spitzensportförderung in den letzten
vier jahren verdoppelt ich bin gespannt
in die ihn auf der einen seite sind neu
im koalitionsvertrag es gebe überhaupt
nichts drin welcher mittel aufwuchs
angebracht ist und er strebt wird für
den spitzensport wissen sie was wir
erreicht haben wir haben eine nationale
strategie sportgroßveranstaltungen ins
werk gesetzt auch in dem neuen
koalitionsvertrag findet sich kein
einziger satz keine einzige aussage dazu
wie sie mit dieser nationale strategie
sportgroßveranstaltungen die wir in den
letzten vier jahren gemeinsam mit den
ländern gemeinsam mit dem vsb erarbeitet
haben weiter umgehen wollen ich würde
sie schon bitten noch weiter stehen zu
bleiben weil wir diese ihre frage will
ich wirklich unheimlich dankbar bin die
gelegenheit gibt noch einmal deutlich
darauf hinzuweisen was wir alles gemacht
haben in der letzten legislaturperiode
der kollege wiese hat das corona hilfen
profisport programm angesprochen was hat
die wissentlich übergangen hat und nicht
erwähnt hat dass dieses corona hilfs und
profisport programm ausschließlich auch
initiative dieser fraktion der cdu csu
fraktion ins werk gesetzt wurde sie
jetzt sich jetzt mit den lorbeeren zu
schmücken die auch die cdu csu fraktion
zurück gehen heute ich schon mit verlaub
etwas feige und etwas zweifelhaft
es geht jetzt nicht darum dass aus der
koalition noch hinweise gegeben werden
wie diese rede jetzt noch ergänzt werden
kann ich lasse auch keine zweite
zwischenfragen
sonst haben wir eine verdoppelung der
rede zu einem sehr wichtigen themen in
die stärkung des ehrenamtes und wir sind
die fraktion des ehrenamtes im herzen
läuft sei falsch einsetzt meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren was sich dann
wiederum auf der einen seite zum sport
findet ist eine sehr nebulöse eine
seriöse aussage zu einer unabhängigen
instanz die gegründet werden soll zur
mittelvergabe da habe ich schon eine
konkrete nachfrage meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren und auch sehr verehrte
frau ministerin wir müssen da unheimlich
aufpassen weil die einrichtung einer
unabhängigen instanz zur mittelvergabe
in der sportförderung könnte natürlich
bedeuten dass das bundesinnenministerium
aber auch der haushaltsgesetzgeber hier
in seinen möglichkeiten ausgenutzt wird
herausgenommen wird und ich bin der
festen überzeugung der deutsche
bundestag als haushaltsgesetzgeber darf
sich dies nicht gefallen lassen meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren ich bin
selbst sehr sportbegeistert wie sie hat
darauf hingewiesen und wenn man sich mal
ansieht der weltrekord im hochsprung der
männer liegt momentan bei 2 meter 45 ich
würde mal sagen als eine ambitiöse
regierung würde ich erwarten dass man
sich dann auch das ziel setzt über 245
zu springen das war es jetzt hier im
koalitionsvertrag steht und mit verlaub
was wir heute von der neuen bundes
sportministerin gehört hat das reicht
gerade mal um die hürden höhe bei den
männern das ist ein meter 06 zu
überspringen für mehr reicht dies aus
dem koalitionsvertrag zur sportpolitik
steht mit sicherheit nicht wir werden
aber kollegen als ersten punkt setzt
können sich sicher sein zu all diesen
themen die ich genannt haben integration
inklusion stärkung des gehaltes des
kinder und jugendsports werden wir
entsprechende vorschläge machen und
entsprechende impulse geben herzlichen
dank
trevor meier war das hier für die
unionsfraktion und
zum bereich ihnen das gehört natürlich
auch der bereich sport traditionell und
deswegen am ende hier dieser rede noch
einmal dieser vergleich von stefan mayr
die ministerin dazu gehört
zunächst redner jetzt matthias helferich
ein fraktionsloser abgeordneter
frau bundesministerin jüngst in einem
interview wenn die bürger unseres landes
diesen anspruch auf sicherheit haben
frage ich mich warum sie in diesen
anspruch verwehren warum konnte der
23-jährige afghanischer drogen dealer
ubs in meinem wahlkreis der dortmunder
nordstadt wo übrigens die armen menschen
leben zunächst eine elfjährige und
sodann aus der untersuchungshaft
entlassen eine 13 jährige brutal
vergewaltigen haben diese mädchen keinen
anspruch auf und innere sicherheit in
unserem land folgt man hier im
abstimmungsverhalten im hessischen
landtag wird diese afghanische
kinderschänder in deutschland verbleiben
dürfen sie stimmten ja bereits für ein
abschiebestopp nach afghanistan was
können zum beispiel die bürger des
dortmunder stadtteils scharnhorst
erleben auch die armen menschen in der
halloween-nacht von 200 jugendlichen
terrorisiert wurden von ihnen erwarten
die jungen iraker syrer libanesen und
sie dürfen ja nicht fehlen jungen
afghanen randalierten zerstörten
geschäfte und beschossen die polizei mit
pyrotechnik haben die menschen in
scharnhorst keinen anspruch auf innere
sicherheit die flutopfer in nrw übrigens
auch arme menschen wurden nicht nur
durch das wasser geschädigt nein sie
wurden auch opfer vom plündereien mehr
als 140 tatverdächtige fast 90 prozent
davon ausländer oder personen mit
migrationshintergrund aus 24 ländern
befanden sich unter den tätern unter
ihnen rumänen türken syrer iraker
kongolesen libanesen und natürlich
afghanen haben die flutopfer in
nordrhein westfalen keinen anspruch auf
innere sicherheit nein sie werden laut
ihrer agenda nichts für diese menschen
tun denn sie haben ja bereits erklärt
dass der rechtsextremismus die größte
gefahr für unsere gesellschaft sei und
rechtsextremist ist inzwischen jeder der
volk sagt oder spazieren geht was auf
uns zukommt ist klar der
verfassungsschutz wird weiter
instrumentalisiert die demokratische
opposition dann saniert und friedliche
spaziergänger kriminalisiert doch die
bürger oder untere schloss mit und ohne
migrationshintergrund den saal
versichert wir werden auf den anspruch
achtgeben dass die innere sicherheit in
diesem land erleben dürfen vielen dank
matthias helferich war das einer der
fraktionslosen abgeordneten erst regel
sie von sie einmal in den bundestag
eingezogen weil die landesliste
nordrhein-westfalen aber nie teil der fw
fraktion gewesen
und hat ja auch rederecht wenn auch auf
der tribüne unten im saal gilt zweig
plus sebastian hartmann jetzt der letzte
redner zu diesem tagesordnungspunkt
frau bundesinnenminister in eine schöne
bezeichnung vom bundesinnenministerium
endlich eine innenministerin in
deutschland mit dem wechsel von der
unions geführten großen koalition hin zu
einer spd geführten koalition auf
augenhöhe mit den liberalen den grünen
leitet sich tatsächlich in diesem land
ein paradigmenwechsel 3 und es ist gut
dass wir zu beginn dieser orientierungs
debatten gleich mit dem bereich der
innenpolitik beginnen um orientierung zu
geben meine damen und herren wir sind
angetreten dieses land zu modernisieren
aber auch entlang eines modernen
gesellschaft bildes zu liberalisieren
und das ist lange überfällig und das
wird diese drei koalitionspartner auf
augenhöhe verbinden liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen was wir allerdings erlebt
haben ist dass manche dinge nicht ganz
einbruch sind sondern auch etwas
kontinuität gesucht wird die union
erleidet einen phantomschmerz
vergangener regierungsverantwortung und
tut so als ob sie in den 16 jahren in
denen sie verantwortung getragen hat mit
alledem nichts zu tun hat sie suchen
sich das so mal eben aus aber wofür sie
auch verantwortung tragen ist etwas was
für eine erschütterung des vertrauens in
den institutionen gesorgt hat die haben
die sparrunden nach vorne gestellt als
es darum ging personal einzusparen der
handlungsfähige start ist
grundvoraussetzung dafür dass eben das
gelingt was nach vorne gestellt wird ja
es ist der dreiklang von freiheit
sicherheit und da darf ich ergänzen
liebe fdp und rechtsstaatlichkeit
freiheit hat als voraussetzung die
sicherheit meine damen und herren nur
wer sich sicher fühlt in diesem land
wird auch sein und ihre freiheiten
ausleben und darum liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen tarieren wir das neu aus ja die
sicherheitsarchitektur sie wird
überarbeitet und evaluiert überwachungs
gesamtrechnung ist das stichwort aber
alle bürgerinnen und bürger die
demokraten demokraten in diesem land
können sich sicher sein wer dieses land
und diese demokratie der erfolgreichste
republik jeden tag verteidigt ob in den
vereinen in den sportvereinen
initiativen oder auch dafür zu sorgen
dass man eben nicht den raum den
rechtsextremen überlässt die versuchen
mit gewalt auf der straße etwas
durchzusetzen was nicht spaltung der
gesellschaft ist sondern der
verächtlichmachung unserer demokratie
sie können sich sicher sein wir sorgen
dafür dass dieser rechtsstaat zu
schützen wird liebe kolleginnen und
dazu gehört es auch ist anders
auszutarieren ja es entscheiden sich
viele millionen menschen jeden tag aufs
neue für diese demokratie und sie sind
es die dieses land zusammenhalten ob in
den impfzentren die ärztinnen und ärzte
ob es die ehrenamtlerinnen und
ehrenamtler sind und wir werden viele
dinge nun endlich anpacken die viel zu
lange hängen geblieben sind ob es die
fragen des modernen aufstellens des
bevölkerungsschutzes liebe union dafür
haben auch sie verantwortung getragen
dass nichts voran gekommen ist sie haben
blockiert jetzt werden wir den
bevölkerungsschutz voranbringen wenn es
um die chancen im schlaf cyber raum gibt
dass wir auch demokraten und demokraten
im netz vor angriffen hass und hetze
schützen dann werden wir dafür sorgen
dass auch dort freiheit geschützt wird
und gleichzeitig sicherheitsbehörden in
die lage versetzt werden auch straftaten
zu verfolgt das muss zusammenkommen
ein rechtsstaat liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
wir werden das mit investitionen
versehen aber auch mit der anpassung von
gesetzen es ist nicht ausgeschlossen
dass wir das eine oder andere gesetze
und das ist auch so fest vereinbart es
ist nicht nur die freiheits kommission
an aber es gibt immer eine klare
orientierung
manche hier im haus sind auf der suche
nach dieser orientieren wir brauchen
auch eine starke demokratische
opposition die daran mitwirkt die
herzliche einladung gilt auch an
diejenigen dann möchte ich dann etwas an
herrn höferlin anknüpfen ja es ist eine
einladung auch zu einem anderen
miteinander in diesem haus das parlament
wird eine sehr zentrale rolle einnehmen
dazu laden wird die demokratische kräfte
ein wie das nicht geht haben wir gesehen
bei den hetzern und den spaltern die das
hier im haus versucht haben
auseinanderzutreiben dieses land ist ein
starkes land ist ein sicheres land wir
werden diese bewährungsprobe unserer
demokratie mit bravour bestehen liebe
kollegen
sebastian hat man war das für die
spd-fraktion und er war der letzte
redner
hierzu dem bereich inne